Tim Draper is a venture capitalist who's
on a quest for a future for a fantastic
future I should say and he's putting his
money where his mouth is in a lot of
companies that he thinks will stand the
world on its ear he's the founder of
Draper and associates and dfj and the
founder of Draper university is school
for entrepreneurs out in california
joins us from san francisco Tim thanks
so much for spending some time with us
today thanks for having me I I got I got
pretty into these micro SAC companies
when I found out that you were investing
in them last week I've been reading all
about them but you have a major SAC
company that you want to talk about as
well SpaceX let me ask you about your
your hopes for SpaceX is future and your
thoughts on the crash that we that we
saw last month oh there are there's some
great opportunities in space space the
final frontier we're very excited about
space my partner Steve Jurvetson sort of
lettuce in that direction he's a rocket
enthusiast but we love Elon Musk Elon
Musk says hey we're going to Mars and he
gets the best engineers and he makes
great things happen and on the way to
Mars we're gonna have an awful lot of
great things great opportunities where
we're thinking that not only all these
micro satellite companies planet labs
skybox which we sold to Google are going
to be make it so that we can see crops
see other things from space and and
predict you know what if we have a
potential natural disaster a lot of
really fun and interesting things are
gonna happen in space over the next 10
or 15 years well planet labs apparently
helps investors as well we a great story
in the Bloomberg about that from Jeff
Kearns a few days ago I love your Farr
sort of far-flung
ideas that obviously gets the most media
coverage as well but when you say go to
Mars
how serious are you and how would that
pay off as an investor oh I think I
think this the sky's the limit there's
so many different
opportunities that happen many different
technologies along the way get us to
Mars and those technologies are are
effective for new new businesses here on
earth and for businesses that are
monitoring the earth and businesses that
could improve our healthcare or our
fitness or whatever they could they
could create a lot of different
interesting opportunities researchers
use space to do to create new molecules
in zero gravity there there are many
opportunities that happen as you project
to great goals like like get to Mars Tim
back to SpaceX for one moment but but
the question kind of extends to this
other stuff that that we were just
discussing regarding Mars as well the
most recent SpaceX crash reminds us that
this is still a very risky business how
long in your opinion before SpaceX is
going to be a mature enough company
which is to say not so risky company
that it can go public because as a
venture capitalist you don't mind or I
wouldn't say not mine but you're
prepared right for some losses the kinds
of losses and failures that public
market investors really don't sign up
for you know it's interesting space act
as SpaceX launches a certain size
payload into space for one two hundredth
of the cost that is that NASA was
spending for the same payload so they
could they could crash 199 Rockets for
every one that went up and they'd still
be doing better than our US government
was yeah but you wouldn't exactly have a
business though well you'd be better off
so in any case having one one rocket go
down is not a big disaster I mean it's a
disaster for that rocket but but there
are and there were just as many rockets
that went down when the US was working
on it space is rockets are flammable
that things could go wrong
but but I think it's it's the kind of
thing that that pushes us forward as it
was a society and makes creates more
progress to take chances like that well
in SpaceX a SpaceX though is incredibly
successful but to Eric's point of VCs
having to sort of push through the times
when they deal with losses I wonder how
you deal with the losses in in Bitcoin
you know I I've been following your
progress through this I'm a Bitcoin user
myself and it's coming back it is sure
looks like things are starting to move
back for Bitcoin I mean Greece all of
these countries that were you where the
citizens don't trust their currency is
it's a great opportunity for Bitcoin to
come in there and and it's great
opportunity for those countries to to
get all of those Bitcoin entrepreneurs
focused on on improving that country's
currency and the way they move money
around this is a great opportunity for
Bitcoin this is a great time but I
wonder what about being a Bitcoin
entrepreneur I mean you and your son
Adam invested a number of Bitcoin
companies that have bought tens of
thousands of bitcoins as well or any of
the businesses that you're looking at
right now on the path to making money oh
actually quite a few are profitable yeah
Bitcoin has been profitable for a lot of
a lot of entrepreneurs from the word go
some of these Bitcoin exchanges some of
the remittances companies yeah there are
quite a few but but the ones that are
getting us also that we can so that we
can use and spend Bitcoin more more
easily so that it's like using your
credit card those companies are taking a
little longer to get going and I think
we will be spending Bitcoin very freely
within a year or two let me finally ask
you you you're the third generation of
Draper VCS
your kids are taking that over and
you've also got Draper university what
what are you teaching people what do you
instill in your kids
makes them able to find a new idea and
invest in it or start up a business
successfully I mean what what are the
one thing what would be one thing that
you would pass along well I think our
society doesn't allow failure schools
don't allow failure and so one of our
the credo that the students all say in
the morning is I will fail and fail
again until I succeed and what that does
is it allows people the flexibility to
try new things to see great things and
see see if long-term potential outweighs
the risk that you take early early on
and I think having that perspective I
think is quite a valuable thing and it's
it's been very effective at Draper
university it's been very effective with
my four children they seem to be doing
amazing things and and I think it's a
it's a good it's a good way to live is
to say look if I fail in one way I'll
just learn from it and I'll try
something else it's the old try and try
again until you succeed right and that
makes a big difference Tim thanks so
much for your time really appreciate it
Tim Draper there from Draper associates
and dfj founder and I like his daughter
has a show the valley girl show you're
seeing Jessi Draper show I haven't I
recommend checking it out very
interesting stuff